thanks to brilliant for helping support
this episode
hey crazies a black hole is what you get
when you
cram matter and light into a small
enough space
the outer edge of that space is called
the event horizon
it's the ultimate in compactification
nothing can escape
it but wait the universe used to be
really small right
if we imagine time in reverse there must
have been a moment when all the matter
in the observable universe was
compressed that much
how did the universe escape
[Music]
this episode was made possible by
generous supporters on patreon
so the size of a black hole at least a
non-rotating one is given by something
called the swarshield radius
sh far schwarzschild's fart
shield whatever it's named after my
buddy carl
who found the first exact solution to
einstein's equation
seriously he was a total banff anyway
carl's radius for a black hole depends
on one thing
mass well technically energy but that
energy becomes mass inside the black
hole
the point is all you have to do is plug
in a mass
and you get out a radius you get the
size of whatever black hole that much
mass would make
it tells us we have to cram the earth
into a space
this small to turn it into a black hole
that's a tiny amount of space
of course it's impossible to do this
with the earth but it
is possible with masses a few times
larger than our sun
it takes that much gravity the
observable universe has more than three
suns in it right
oh yeah a lot more if you plug the total
mass of the observable universe
into carl's radius what you get is
528 billion light years what
that's over 10 times the size of the
observable universe
could the universe actually be ins no no
don't be ridiculous
the observable universe is not inside a
black hole
for one very important reason this
calculation is
bull nuggets you can't just plug numbers
into an equation and be like this means
something
carl's radius requires that that mass
ball
be surrounded by comparatively empty
space
you know somewhere to escape to
successfully or not
that's true for a planet it's true for a
star
it's even true for this black hole but
it's not true for the universe
there's no empty outside to escape to
it's the same
uniform universe everywhere that means
this doesn't apply
which means this number is completely
meaningless
like i said bowl nuggets the universe is
not inside a black hole so it doesn't
have an event horizon
or does it an event horizon
is just a boundary beyond which we
cannot observe events
the universe does have a boundary like
that it actually has three boundaries
that we call horizons
the cosmic event horizon the particle
horizon
and the hubble horizon but to understand
them
we all need to be on the same page about
the universe space
is expanding and this makes distant
galaxies recede from each other
the farther away they are the faster
they're moving away
but that that animation grossly
understates the scales we're working on
here
galaxies this close could easily be
moving toward us
rather than away in fact our closest
neighbor andromeda
is moving toward us it's on a collision
course
it'll hit us in a few billion years and
put on quite a show for a few billion
more
when we say galaxies are moving away
from us we mean galaxies
in other superclusters this is much
closer to the true scale of the universe
individual galaxies are too small each
point of light
is a cluster of galaxies those clusters
form superclusters that collect into
giant filaments
but without some basis for scale this
looks more like a zoom than an expansion
so we'll go back to the individual
galaxies
just keep in mind that it's it's not to
scale
the universe is big like really big
mind-bogglingly big it's so big that the
recession speeds of some galaxies can
get out of hand the whole horizon
this is where galaxies are moving away
at the speed of light
it happens at about 14.5 billion light
years from us
just a little past the 13.8 billion you
might expect given the age of the
universe
any galaxy farther away is receding from
us faster than light
fast fast but we can still see them so
the hubble horizon isn't really a
horizon it's just where things start to
get weird
light from beyond it can arrive on earth
as long as it's not coming from too far
beyond it
see the hubble horizon grows so it can
catch up to some of the light
allowing us to see it the limit of our
vision
is a little farther away the cosmic
event horizon
nothing that happens outside this
horizon will ever be seen by us
ever it's located about 16.7 billion
light years away
just a little past the hubble horizon
now
you might have heard the observable
universe is a lot bigger than that
and it is remember measurements get real
weird beyond the hubble horizon and
that's because light takes time to get
places
if light is emitted from just inside the
cosmic event horizon today
it won't arrive on earth until the
distant future
by then those galaxies could easily be
beyond the event horizon
it works the other way too if we're
receiving the light now
it was emitted a long time ago it could
easily have been emitted when a galaxy
was inside the event horizon
by now it's beyond the event horizon but
we're still receiving the light from
when it wasn't
so how far away is the farthest stuff
now pretty far
the particle horizon this
represents the limit of our vision the
current size of the observable universe
it's 46.5 billion light years away
a whopping three times farther than the
other two horizons
this is how far away from us anything
we've ever received light from
could have gotten since the beginning of
time it's the current location of the
farthest stuff we can see
the hydrogen plasma that emitted the
cosmic microwave background
mind you it's not hydrogen plasma
anymore it has since collected into
galaxies
but we don't get to see what it looks
like now remember it's way past the
cosmic event horizon
we only get to see what it looked like
13.8 billion years ago
because that's when the light was
emitted back when the particle horizon
was inside the cosmic event horizon
you know we could actually graph this
out across time if we use
models the hubble horizon that place
where galaxies are receding at the speed
of light
is always the closest horizon to us
because it isn't really a horizon
it just separates the familiar physics
from the weird physics
the cosmic event horizon was the
farthest of the horizons in the early
universe
unfortunately as space expanded the
particle arise and overtook it pretty
quickly
where they cross is the most recent
state of the particle horizon
we'll ever get to see but the light from
back then has been traveling through
expanding space
so as the particle horizon approaches
the cosmic event horizon
the light takes longer and longer to get
to us
it'll actually take an infinite amount
of time to see what happened when they
crossed
cosmology is so weird in the present
the hubble horizon is 14.5 billion light
years away
the cosmic event horizon is 16.7 billion
light years away
and the particle horizon is 46.5 billion
light years away
i i know these these numbers are
ridiculously big so if it helps
ignore the billion measure the numbers
in gigalight years in giga years like i
do
it'll help make the future of all three
horizons a little less overwhelming
anyway let's go back to the cosmic web
and see what this all actually looks
like
the cosmic event horizon starts out the
farthest
but is overtaken by the particle horizon
within a few billion years
this is what they look like now at 14.5
16.7 and 46.5 gigalight years
respectively
eventually though the particle horizon
will expand way out of view
the hubble horizon and the cosmic event
horizon will settle at about
17.5 gigalight years trapping us in a
bubble
forever it might not be a black hole but
it's still
definitely a trap at least until we
invent some kind of ftl drive
but the weirdest part of this whole
thing is that we can see galaxies that
are already beyond the cosmic event
horizon because their light is old
all the galaxies you're seeing in this
deep field image
are just ghosts from the distant past
and that's what they'll always be
forever
the cosmos is terrifying oh
so got any questions about these cosmic
horizons
please ask in the comments thanks for
liking and sharing this video
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember
it's okay to be a little crazy do you
want to learn something new
well brilliant is the place for you it's
a website and
app that makes learning accessible and
fun
brilliance approach is based on problem
solving and active learning
it's all about seeing concepts visually
interacting with them
and then answering questions that make
you think there are no tests or grades
just pick a course and get started
if you make a mistake no big deal just
check out the explanations and learn
from them
with over 60 courses there's something
for everyone
train yourself in basic logic learn to
code if you want something more advanced
try out differential equations or neural
networks
if this sounds like a service you'd like
to use go to brilliant.org
science asylum today the first 200
subscribers will get 20
off an annual subscription
[Music]
thanks to everyone who tried to help me
pronounce ramon
eek hall i'm sure i'm missing a sound in
there somewhere
anyway i i guess this ramon guy is a
pretty big deal in the neuroscience
world
the socratica channel has a video all
about him if you're interested
link in the doobly-doo and thanks for
watching